we saw an interview with President Obama
when he was first in office and he said
well everyone knows that the New Deal
worked hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason
TV and today we're talking with Anita
Folsom and Bert fall some authors
recently of New Deal or Brod deal and
the new book
FDR goes to war how expanded executive
power spiraling national debt and
restricted civil liberties shaped
wartime America Folsom's thank you for
talking to us Thank You Nick you know
with you let's get right to it
FDR goes to war this is a period where
historians and the American population
seems to say you know what FDR whatever
you might say about his economic
policies he was a great wartime leader
how did he expand executive power and
why was that a bad thing well he sets up
the office of Price Administration the
OPA and what you have there is a price
fixing for all sorts of products farm
products the prices were fixed the
amount of gasoline that you were able to
get at the pump it's fixed commodities
that you were able to buy in the grocery
store it's often fixed rent control
introduced in a big way but is that
necessary because it's a wartime economy
everything's got to be done for the
greater good or that was the argument it
was done for the to win the war and
Americans went along with it but part of
the reason that we were in such poor
shape to fight a war was that during the
1930s the FDR and the federal government
soaked up so much in taxes that they
didn't encourage business factory output
went down every year of the 1930s in the
United States so that when the war
suddenly loomed even in 40 and 41 it was
very hard to get the industry in America
revitalized and FDR came in and in
addition to price controls he also had
the war production board which took over
allocation and production of almost
everything now we can at least say you
know he you know we did win World War
two so something positive came out of
that and that's fair to say that and he
plays a role in that because he shifted
to giving incentives for businesses to
produce rather than the heavy
taxes which he imposed on them in the
1930s now all of the spending under the
New Deal as well as then in the in the
wartime economy I mean that leads to
spiralling national debt what happened
to the debt it skyrocketed you look at
1932 the highest tax rate anyone had to
pay was 25 percent the national debt was
about 18 or so maybe up to 20 billion
dollars started when Hoover came in at
16 went up to maybe 20 under Roosevelt
it virtually doubles in his first two
terms a doubling of the national debt
then during World War two
you go from about 40 50 billion up to
260 billion dollars national debt what
I'm saying is that the interest payment
on that debt was roughly what the
national debt was when Roosevelt came
into office and what what are the
effects of that amount and that rapid
increase of the debt you know how does
that affect things
well FDR has to try to cover a lot of
that debt obviously with higher taxes
you only have 5 percent of Americans
paying income tax in 1940 41 by 43 you
have 65 percent paying income tax he
also has the clout to push through
withholding but the the implication is
then after the war is that high taxes
can very easily continue and as we know
higher income taxes do continue after
that right and what in the 50s top
marginal tax rates ended up reaching as
high as something like 90% 94% was what
the top rate was on all income over
$200,000 when Roosevelt died as I say
tonight 13 years earlier 1932 the top
rate was 25% what and now but federal
spending after Roosevelt is dead but
once World War Two is over
federal spending declined rapidly it did
and that's the key decision that ended
the Great Depression the Keynesian
wanted to continue massive government
spending all sorts of programs to help
the unemployed who would be coming back
from overseas but and this was the
prediction was you know we're
demobilizing massive hundred millions
and millions of men come
back to a labor pool that's already
tight it's going to be a disaster but
the government actually cut spending and
cut a bunch of programs and the economy
flourish the American people after three
years of war three years and eight
months were tired of all the regulations
and the shortages there was enough of a
love of Liberty that Americans wanted
was it a love of Liberty or a love of
butter well Bob you know butter and guns
that's what they always say but they
wanted their freedom back freedom to
make their own decisions and to produce
and buy products and Congress enough
congressman in 1945 and 46 and 47
realized that high taxes had been
ruinous and Truman wanted to institute
high taxes again and Congress rebelled
and said no and they cut taxes and
unemployment in 46 was a remarkable 3.9
percent with all those men coming back
well let's talk about civil liberties
because that's that is an issue that
Roosevelt has never really or at least
since pretty much since you know 1950 or
so hasn't gotten a free pass on what
happened to civil liberties during World
War two and and why is it problematic it
is well we have massive wiretapping even
though the Supreme Court decision had
declared that that was not the right
thing to do Roosevelt was engaging
heavily in wiretapping he starts with
wiretapping opponents because they may
be aiding the enemy in some way it ends
up by he's wiretapping his wife he's
wiretapping some of his advisors we
start then with the heavy taxes and the
audits the heavy audits that go in on
people who are opposed to Roosevelt then
you have the helpful for people who
support Roosevelt the helpful effort on
his part to get the IRS off of their
back like Lyndon Johnson what now the
biggest case are the internment of the
Japanese courts and resident aliens who
were Italian and German also faced
imprisonment is that right that's right
many some of them were arrested if they
were still German citizens certainly and
Italian citizens what what was the mood
of the country about the Japanese
internment was it overall in favor of it
or was it you know this this is really
wrong it varied I think from family to
family and
some of that again was economic
incentives many people in California
said to say really were not were for
internment of the Japanese the Japanese
were were very competitive in producing
fruits and vegetables in California and
other businesses and people on the west
coast didn't always get the point that
they were many of them were American
citizens the japanese-americans right
but they were interned a hundred and ten
thousand and at the urging of her a
warrant right career became over on who
is Attorney General and then became
governor was running supporting the
internment of the Japanese we ever
Express you know the idea that that was
a wrong how did he deal with he he never
got over the fact that he shouldn't have
done that he he had done it for
political reasons he he knew it would
please California voters and after the
war he thought you know my god I just
trampled all over the constitution doing
that and I shouldn't have done it now
you know history is something that we
always you know we created in the moment
and look back we create a usable pass or
sure useful genealogies what is the you
know what what's the the main message
that you want to bring across by
revisiting FDR is kind of a geographic
treatment of his wartime presidency when
Bert had written New Deal a raw deal and
then we were dealing with all of the
publicity surrounding that we saw an
interview with President Obama when he
was first in office and he said well
everyone knows that the New Deal worked
and we were just amazed to hear him say
that of course that is the idea that is
taught in Ivy League colleges all over
and colleges all over the country we
have to come to a realization that these
big government ideas do not lead to
prosperity
that's one of the lessons it also
influenced the issues of today the the
idea of guaranteed medical care for
example leading to Obamacare it comes
right out of World War two the idea of
we need to have aid to housing that's
what Roosevelt said in his 1944 campaign
that we that people have a right to a
decent home that's a direct quote
well what constitutes a decent home well
you start out with urban renewal under
Truman and others you go to the
Community Reinvestment Act
they're Carter and later Clinton and you
see the formation of politics today
coming right out of World War two and
mistaken ideas that government programs
are the solution to economic and
political problems well well Anita and
Bert Folsom I want to thank you for
speaking of recent TV about thank you
book our passion then the new book is
FDR goes to war how expanded executive
power spiraling national debt and
restricted civil liberties shaped
wartime America thanks again for reason
TV I'm Nicholas